this is awesome ben texted me or like
slacked me while we were doing this and
he goes steph's been uh
spitting fire for the last 50 minutes so
this is badass
about to see my first a million got to
the safe and it's filling up got to the
bank it's not big
what's going on um
what's up good how are you
i'm good all right you're back shawn is
on a family vacation and you are the sub
and i think it's a good sub so you sent
me this document that we're gonna we're
gonna go through a ton of stuff there's
so much stuff on here
how uh
are you is this like a list that you've
been
keeping for months or is this just you
made this just for this this is part of
a list i've been keeping for months i uh
i keep this list in my evernote that
just every time i see a new idea whether
it's from like a newsletter or something
you guys talk about on my first million
that i want to respond to i just have a
running list so this is probably like a
quarter of that bigger list what this is
15 pages how many words like just what
we have here is like 10 000 words
we should share this i mean at least
parts of it because we're not gonna get
through all of this
this is amazing i if i was you i
wouldn't share this i would charge
people for it this is good
i mean
there's definitely things that i'm
excluding from here you know you don't
share the ones that you actually want to
build
you uh
so
you told me one time that you want to
become a billionaire i think i want to
we'll see if that actually happened well
i said who cares if it happens or not
but you said that's what you wanted
do you um what are you going to do to
become that i mean i feel like if i ever
become a billionaire we're going to talk
hopefully about tyler perry later it has
to come from
building something on my own i need to
have equity in something like you don't
become a billionaire from
working for a company and buying etfs
well there's a few examples but the
likelihood of becoming a billionaire is
slim to none the likelihood become of
becoming a billionaire by being an early
employee somewhere is much slimmer of
that subset but it's possible it's
definitely possible
um should we talk about these companies
of one which i feel like are kind of
anti-not anti-billionaire but a
different approach to building yes and i
actually don't think they're
anti-billionaire i think you can become
a billionaire this way but just so
people know so this is steph smith steph
you work at the hustle you basically
helped me start trends and you ran it
for a while and you still kind of run it
but you also do like a bunch of other
different projects and you have this gum
road book called doing content right is
that right yep and it made like 150 g's
in the first year or something like that
right yep exactly and you are the type
so we
we aren't like really partners anymore
but i felt like when we when you ran
trends i viewed it a little bit like a
partnership so i've worked with you
pretty closely for a while now now that
now we're just friends but uh
is that out is that all accurate what am
i missing i think so yeah i uh i build
stuff on the side for fun taught myself
to code a couple years ago and now i
also have a podcast so if people like
what they hear hear um it's called the
[__] you don't learn in school that's my
little plug
and you are very
you and i are similar in that there's
like it's kind of like sean like there's
like this this like overlap of things
that are very very similar between us
but there's things that are very
different in that what you're different
about is that you sweat the details uh
like crazy and you're pretty technical
in the sense of like
i really think it's just you're just
smarter than me like you could just
figure things out like
you can just you can just figure certain
things out so your research is actually
typically more like in-depth and
technical than my research and i like
that
thanks i mean i don't know if i actually
saw the details if anyone knows me
closely like if you'd have asked cal
he'd be like no she's like a mess so i
appreciate that i come off that way
so let's talk about companies of one so
you have a list of like
ten or seven companies that are run by
one person that are shockingly big let's
go through some of them and uh talk
about them
yeah so i think you called out two
before so i'm gonna just call out those
two quickly you called up built with
before which is the site that basically
can tell what a site is built with is it
built with wordpress or squarespace or
what plugins is it is the site using and
that one at the time when you found it
was i think doing around 14 million and
then you've also covered nomad list and
remote okay by peter levels and those
two i think together are doing around a
million a year and those two i think are
both completely solo founders i know
peter certainly is um but there are a
couple others so have you heard of ugg
monk
well hold on so built with so people
know built with is like maybe one of the
most impressive ones here but not the
but one of built with is like it's like
a i think they have a plug-in as well
but it's a website you go to
builtwith.com you enter in the hustle.co
let's say you want to you you see
something on our website that you like
and you want to copy and you're like
how'd they build that what plugins do
they use what whatever you use built
with and they make money because uh they
like
what do they do i think they like sell
people's data or something
i'm not sure actually let me look this
up because
i know they get a crazy amount of
traffic look they've got plans on their
site so they've got a basic plan i don't
know what you get with it but it's 295
dollars oh i know what you get you get
basically i believe you sign up and it
tells you uh people's so it crawls all
these websites and it tells you what
type of features they have on their
website and what type of plug-ins and i
think you pay money and it'll say we
have the emails or contact information
of all types of people who use blank
plug-in and you sell a plug-in that is
complementary to that therefore pay
money and you can now target them and
advertise against them or things like
that
yeah they charge so their basic plan is
three thousand dollars a year their pro
is five thousand their team is 10 000.
there's a cool little trick they have on
their pricing page if you go to it and
you hover over they have like
technologies keywords and they have
these little gifs
that they're actually like showing what
you would get with the product i've
never actually seen that before so
that's a cute little hack
and it's built by basically one guy in
australia um all right so what are some
of the other companies
okay so i was gonna call it ugg monk so
this one's not as big i actually don't
know exactly
how much they're making but it's a
really simple e-commerce store they
started
just selling really nice t-shirts which
sounds like okay like there's enough
t-shirt stores out there um but this guy
jeff sheldon he focused on just really
high quality shirts and then now he's
moved into almost like productivity
stuff if you are you in the doc i'm
looking at ugg monk so when i go to ugg
monk i see
like a pen holder and i see
um like a a to-do list
like a
it's like cute well-designed like pen
holders which doesn't sound neat but it
honestly it looks pretty sick
yeah it looks surprisingly sick if you
go to let me if you click in the dock
where it says look at this if you click
that that is his setup and he he's like
one of those builders who i think has
built a little twitter following as well
and he just has this beautiful
desk set up which is like the perfect ad
and i oh i've seen this it looks awesome
i never thought i'd want to go and buy
like a 100 to-do list but i
i think i'm gonna buy one yeah i
it's just like
cute easy to use like mid-century modern
stuff yeah i'm on board how much revenue
does he do i'm not sure but i'm pretty
sure he does several million a year he
gets over 200 000 page views a month um
and he's been going at this for several
years so i know he makes enough to have
left his full-time job several years ago
and he's grown a lot since then so i'd
probably say a couple
wow that's crazy all right that's a
that's a good find it's just one guy
he's the only employee i think so i mean
he's he he probably has
some staff now that he's been growing
but i i'm pretty sure he doesn't have a
big team all right what's next all right
card is actually one guy he might have
contractors but card c-a-r-r-d i've
built sites with card people probably
recognize card or they've almost
certainly been on a site built by card
um and it's built by this guy aj and
it's doing one million dollars a year ar
i think he actually just raised money
now so i think he's kind of going for
did he really just raise money i would
love to invest in this
yeah he raised money earlier this year
he was like big in the indie hacker
community and then i think he posted on
indie hackers this year like look i'm
i'm going to raise money i'm going to
you know really go for it but he it's
kind of crazy 2.5 million sites have
been built on card and
yeah
like a million ar so it's a free
platform for building simply uh for
building simple fully responsive
one-page websites that can do anything
um yes i actually think
so there there was this company called
um you remember about me
no what is that about dot me so go to
about dot me at that's the url
um you don't remember that you're i'm
just a little bit older than you
which is like then that few years
probably makes a difference because
about.me when i was just getting started
was considered like the preeminent
builder in this space and they made it
was a one
page website where you can explain stuff
about you and it was started by this guy
named tony conrad i believe his name is
and he's this cool looking dude who uh
is also an investor now and he sold it
after only two years to aol for like 40
million dollars and it was bootstrapped
you see about.me you see how it's like
basically the same thing yeah it reminds
me of you've heard of unsplash right i
love unsplash so or sorry i'm not
thinking of unsplash i'm talking about
unfold unfold is this app that basically
for instagrammers it adds different like
it allows you to kind of piece together
pictures for your instagram story but
they also started these like one pagers
um where basically because all these
instagramers they're like oh i need my
link in bio link in bio is also a site
like that but unfold um was sold
to squarespace i think like last year or
something i don't know for how much
though man i think that these one page
website builders are actually really
cool so there's this other business i
almost invested in i think it's called
mediakits.com or dot co i believe it's
just called media kit and all they did
was built a really slick website builder
where you could create your media kick
kit and send it to people so and uh
whether you're the hustle or you're just
an instagram person you just had this
like uh the hustle.com media kit or like
you know um stephsmith.commediakit
and it was that your media kit was on
there and that sounds like not that
important but it's kind of like docsen
so docsen if you don't know what docsen
is docsen is basically
all it is is powerpoint in the cloud
but email gated so you have to enter
your email and then you get all types of
information so if you use it when you
are creating a pitch deck and you want
to send it to investors so you know who
has it and uh and who views it and how
long they've used it and it's basically
that um
so anyway card is pretty badass that
actually might be one of the highest
potential businesses you have here i
think yeah and i mean he actually runs
card as a subscription business so
that's 1 million ar and i think it's
probably way past that today
i think you're going to like the next
one though go to uh this nextepisode.net
i think it's actually next
episode.net it's the it's such an old
site i think the guy's been running it
for 15 years um and if you just open it
up you'll you'll get a sense of how the
ui hasn't caught up to where we are
today but it's amazing because this
guy's been running it for 15 years guess
how much traffic this thing gets i'm
looking at it on similar web this is
crazy
so what is this called so next dash
episode.net what is this yeah
it's a site where basically
like there's no way i would think that a
site like this would still exist but
people use it um that basically helps
you track your tv shows and it's a
little bit of a community so i think
i've never used it but you know people
watch the bachelor they hang out on this
site and they find other people who
watch the bachelor and they talk about
it um but it's kind of crazy how much
traffic this site gets this is awesome
and so here's why i know this is a big
business so if you go to similar web and
you look at the traffic
the estimated monthly traffic is 3.6
million uniques a month
that's
decent that's not like the best but it's
like really good particularly for one
person but if you go to traffic source
it says that 80 is coming from direct
traffic which basically means that
there's a lot of people that are just
typing in this url and going there on a
consistent basis and if you do that you
probably can have a huge business and it
looks like they've got um a premium
which is only two dollars a month but uh
how big is this so i don't know exactly
how big it is but he's been running it
for 15 years and i know he's definitely
i found him on hacker news one of those
posts that was like hey like who's a
solopreneur who's doing this thing on
their own and he's like i've worked on
this entirely on my own for the last 15
years
so what this is crazy good find i can't
wait so who what's this person's name do
you know uh let me send you
here he is i found him nico nicole yeah
wow this is a good find
how much revenue do you think he does on
this i don't know about today but i'm
assuming like
if he's getting that many million pages
and he's been working on it for 15 years
i'd say like maybe a million a year what
do you think yeah i would agree with
that and it's probably mostly all profit
yeah well i mean he's literally the only
one who works on it
in one of the posts on hacker news he's
like
yeah i started for myself because i
couldn't find such a tool back in the
day and um
basically he's like avoided hiring other
people um because he doesn't want to
like scale through hiring um all right
what else we got
there's a ton on here there's some
there's one called hostify by a guy
named riley who basically um
you know has scaled that to like a
million a month in a year or two um
there's some good stories from back in
the day where apparently surveymonkey
was doing 19 million dollars in revenue
um with 12 employees so not a one-person
thing but plenty of fish is another
example where they were doing apparently
10 million dollars and the guy was by
himself he might have even been
part-time so that's kind of a crazy
story from back in the day too how did
how do you know this about surveymonkey
so it was posted it was actually you
posted about built with a while ago i
think and then i went through all of the
comments of you basically you were like
can anyone tell me something more
efficient than that and um this guy
named tripp posted yeah surveymonkey was
doing 19 million with 12 employees um
and you asked him
if this was documented and basically
someone else commented and was like yeah
tripps do you want us to say this but he
actually invested in surveymonkey in
2009 so he probably knows the numbers
wow this is amazing i've heard this i've
heard rumors about surveymonkey doing
this this is crazy this is so cool so
did i tell you about
how i told you about craigslist right so
the hustle our very first office it was
this apartment it basically it looked
like a town home like like a typical san
francisco town home but it was zoned as
business and on the bottom was this uh
was a piano teacher in the middle it was
like a three-story town home but they
like divvied it up into apartments so
the bottom one was a piano teacher the
middle one was this company called
nugs.net and nuggs.net sells it's like a
marketplace where you can
trade
uh like fish and grateful dead like cds
that you recorded at their concerts and
above that was craigslist and craigslist
moved out and we moved in and this was
in 2016 i think and
which means craigslist at the time the
landlord told me he goes
they were making around
300 million dollars in revenue and they
worked out of this little office and
this office was so small it was
basically a three or two bedroom
apartment and he was like there's
basically like 14 people here and that
was the whole company and
they were so cheap craig was so cheap
that the rent the rent i was paying was
like 500 and i split it with my friend
sieva so the rent for the whole place
was probably only two thousand dollars
so they're paying two or three grand in
rent for this place when they were that
big and they were so cheap that in the
lease apparently it said like toilet
paper is provided by
landlord and every once in a while
uh i think his name was ishmael he would
forget to uh or emanuel a man i forget
it was like this old jewish guy he would
forget to put the toilet paper and
replenish it and they wouldn't pay the
rent they go until we get the toilet
paper you're not getting the rent and uh
they additionally craig worked out his i
used uh craig's room because it had a
kitchen table in one of the bedrooms
that he used as his desk it was like
this ugly kitchen table that was like
his desk but it was really heavy and
they couldn't move it and they just left
it there and that was my desk for a long
time was this like weird kitchen table
and that was out of the craigslist
office and that's how scrappy they were
dude i love that so i mentioned peter
lovells before he's a friend of mine
from bali he once tweeted about this so
i don't feel bad sharing it but he used
to walk around with this like you know
those bags that you get at a grocery
store they're like plastic bags that are
like a dollar yeah so you'd think that
some guy making like a million bucks a
year all profit is gonna like upgrade
his lifestyle he would carry his laptop
around in one of those bags and like
that's it and you'd see him walking
around in flip-flops and a t-shirt and
you'd be like dude like respect because
like you you make a lot of money and
everyone knows that because you have
that open page but he's like walking
around with like a grocery store bag as
his laptop holder that's stupid that's
very stupid it ruined your laptop um
what are some what are some other
smaller ones all right so i want to call
it a couple these are actually uh
also some people i know from bali so
it's it's kind of cool when you live in
a place like chengu because you're just
running into people just like this so
one of them is this thing called banner
bear
so if you click on the link where it
says banner bear that's their open page
so a lot of these people also create
these cool open pages like uh the ones
from nomad list but i wanted to show you
this one because if you scroll down if
you're on the page do you see the modem
the motor i can't even say it the moto
meter
yeah what is this so i'm looking at
basically
a pic pictures of motorcycles
of like nice triumph motorcycles so
basically like he's got his revenue and
you can see his mrr and it's pretty
impressive he's at around an er of 300
thousand i think he only started this
you can see in some time in 2020 um but
he kind of rethought the open page and
he was like you know what i just i don't
want to just show my revenue i want to
show people like what i want to spend
this on so he loves motorcycles and he
has like these different goals so like
if he hits a certain mrr he like unlocks
a new motorcycle um and so i thought
that was just like a kind of cool cool
little thing and you can see just like
peter he shows all of his data like you
have the number of trials per month uh
his churn um obviously the the moto
meter his github commit activity so i
think that's pretty cool because like i
think years ago there was some people
showing their like open revenue but now
people are kind of like rethinking what
they can share
what the hell is banner bear this is so
cool looking what does it do so
basically i think it's it's basically
like an api for generating images so do
you know how like we use we could have
used this at trends honestly remember we
would run events and we'd have to like
go on fiverr and like you know it would
kind of it would it wasn't very
expensive but it takes some time and
you're like oh man like we should just
have like an image template for all of
our events and it has like a certain
background a certain theme and so he's
made it possible to basically
generate images based on certain inputs
so um you don't have to like go and hire
a designer to do that you can like auto
generate images and so some people use
this for like social media right so you
have like a certain theme that aligns
with your brand and you're just like
adjusting like all of your blog posts to
like use banner bear instead of going
and hiring a designer to create an image
for each one this guy's site is
beautiful he reminds me of how do you
say that peter lovells guy is that is it
peter
yep he reminds me of that this guy looks
like an artist
yeah i mean i think what's cool about
all of these folks is like they do the
whole stack like i guess you have to as
a company is one but they do like the
marketing they do the design they do um
the development and what's cool is that
like because they're not necessarily
experts quote unquote in these spaces
like they're just kind of hacking it
together i find they're actually a lot
more creative
right so they're like they're not like
constrained by the marketing degree that
they had you know before and so peter is
like another example where he's he
pretty consistently does pretty cool
things on marketing or on twitter for
example recently he like
instead of paying 10 000 for ads he's
like i'm just giving 10 000 away to like
someone who retweets this and it got
like 11 000 retweets which obviously is
like much more than he would have spent
on ads
this in this website banner bear it was
launched in uh 10 of 2019 so let's round
up to be 2020. so let's say it started
in 2000 january 2020 that means it's
what two years old
yep
is growing pretty well does it say its
growth rate i mean this could be pretty
this could be a really good business
yeah and and it's just him i think he
like might have hired like a part-time
customer service person but yeah it's
going really well
wow this is amazing
how big do you think this could get
i think pretty big because it's actually
like you know it's one of those niche
problems that you're like what like a
you're going to create a product that
auto generates images like who needs
that but then you actually think like
wow every company that has a blog has to
generate all these images on mass every
company that runs something on social
media like i think the reason it's
working is it's actually even though it
seems like a niche problem it's it's a
problem that most companies have
wow all right you want to do you want to
pick a couple more
we can just call out uh one more which
is have you heard of headline
no what's that
how do you find how do you find all this
stuff by the way
well like i said i combed through some
of the threads that you posted before
but headline banner bear nomad list like
these are all people who were nomadic
and i think it's like the indie hacker
community and the nomad community
overlap because they're both kind of
like
rebellious in a way they're like i don't
need to live in one place or like i
don't need to raise venture capital and
so i think there's an overlap there and
so yeah most of these guys are people
that i used to like co-work with in bali
wow
okay so what's headline
so headline is super super
simple app but um
danny the guy who built it built it in
like a couple months and within a year
he sold it for seven figures so all it
was is it was using ai to generate um
kind of like landing page headlines or
copy
um and so if you look at the landing
page it kind of looks like a much more
complex product um but it's actually
pretty simple and um if you've heard of
copy.ai i think there's like similar
elements to it oh hey basically on the
website of headline they use my name
they're writing
wait really say i just noticed that you
must have seen this before i've never
seen this this guy's using my name i've
never that's so funny is he trying to
tell me to use this i don't know because
i also don't know like i said he sold
this so i don't know if he put that
there if the new founders put it there
um
you're wait you're seeing you're seeing
my face and name on this website yeah
totally
god that's so funny why is my face on
here whatever that's cool
uh yeah well this is just like a super
simple one where it's like i love it's
like perfect example of like
just being scrappy building something he
exited seven figures within i think
eight months which is pretty crazy um
and yeah i just i think one theme is
just like
these people find like a niche problem
that isn't or at least seems niche they
solve it has to be an existing problem
that people want solved i think the
thing that a lot of people do wrong when
they're trying to like do their like own
little startup is they look for things
that like
don't really exist but these are like
perfect examples where it's like oh of
course people need sites to like house
their their work of course people need
like nice t-shirts and productivity
stuff of course people need like landing
page copy so i think that's the like one
learning for me how did this guy build
this
he built it in the open on twitter so he
just coded it and he would like keep
giving updates and then i think he
launched it on product hunt like pretty
classic
launch strategy but i think it kind of
blew up after product hunt and then sold
it but it's just built on top of
that gpd3 thing yep
wow all right that's amazing wow i
cannot believe it good fine um
you want to try something else
yeah let's talk about just a couple of
these so another thing that i did which
kind of overlaps with what we talked
about is just like sites that have a
surprising amount of traffic so sites
that you're like wait really like
there's no way and then you look it up
and you're like wow i guess like you
know 20 million people a month actually
look this up so one of them i want to
show you is called glitchin deals have
you heard of glitching
no what's that mean
okay so you know how
like
of course e-commerce is popping off
a lot of companies have e-commerce sites
not all of them have
fully functioning e-commerce sites so
sometimes they glitch right so sometimes
an airline will you know show a a flight
for like 20 bucks that's really meant to
be 200 sometimes you know there will be
something that's a dollar and it's like
really supposed to be 100 it's just like
a decimal place error and this happens
all the time right and apparently
according to the law like if you
advertise it for a certain amount like
you have to sell it for that amount
so there are all these sites that
basically look for glitches and i found
this out because i was at um
my partner's
like family home for christmas last year
and i remember his aunt being like hey
do you want like a podcast mike and i
was like i don't like sure i don't know
like why why do you have she's like i've
got 30. like i just don't have to give
them away and i'm like what do you mean
you have 30 and i guess she found a
glitch in one of these groups and
yeah like she just got 30 podcast mics
that like she she got for free so free
it was free in that case it was free
most of the time it's just like a crazy
wild deal that the company didn't mean
to do
so like i need to buy i'm trying to up
my game and get that garage fridge you
know i'm talking about that garage space
like it's so i can store all my meat and
so i uh on here they've got a 25 garage
fridge i need that freezer yeah
and uh
that's how you know you make it when you
get a garage fridge and um they have one
for 50 and it looks kind of complicated
to use though
yeah so i have to say i've never
actually glitched myself i think it's
one of those like rabbit holes that like
the same way people go and like try to
like enter sweepstakes i think it's like
a similar
phenomenon but there's a ton of people
doing it so this glitch and deal site
gets four million uh page views a month
but it's only been around for a year
2020 i think they must scrape them or
they have at least i think it's actually
a separate glitch site but has they have
a facebook group and this facebook group
has 342 000 members wow guess how many
people post a day in this facebook group
how many 250 plus posts a day that's
today when i checked it had 262 posts
and it was like it was like 11 am so
i'm not that surprised because
when we do giveaways for the hustle
we'll do like a t-shirt giveaway and
like these websites it's like a circular
like they all like copy each other and
it's basically like midwesterny
stay-at-home moms mostly and they love
giveaways and like one time we've like
we're giving away stickers and i saw one
of them post this on like a forum uh
like hey there's this newsletter called
the hustle you just gotta share your
referral link they'll send you stickers
i just got mine and there's hundreds of
people commenting on it like talking
about different strategies that allows
them to get more referrals through the
hustle so they'll get their t-shirt or
their stickers or whatever people look
like this demographic it's mostly women
i've noticed and it's mostly like uh
stay-at-home mom types they love this
[__] they love these deals they love
free stuff
they love it's like it's like a
challenge for them because i remember
asking his aunt like
why did you do this like you don't need
30 podcast mics and she's like i just
wanted to like i just wanted to like win
almost and i think it's so interesting
that so many people are doing this
because like you're saying it's it's
like a crazy amount of people who are
like who probably don't need this stuff
but are like i'm so stoked that i got
like a gas grill on clearance yeah we
were giving away we were giving away
like stickers that said the hustle and
it's like these ladies
like they don't care about business or
tech like they just didn't they didn't
care about our brand but they just
wanted it just because it was available
to get and they felt good yeah it was
crazy to me what else we got
okay so let's go to nugget comfort so if
you want to click on that it is it was
actually something shared in the
transcript a while ago
i don't even know how to explain what
these are they're basically like cool
children's pillows but they're
children's pillows that you can
basically make into like different
shapes and forts and it was just crazy
to think so nugget was i think
started relatively recently it's in the
last year or so i think they had some
mailing lists for a prior product before
that but they made over four million in
sales uh in a month with zero ad spend
so nugget comfort was doing is doing
over four million a month yes
what if you go to so here's how i know
that they're at least pretty big you go
to their website so it looks like
they're based in north carolina you go
to their website and you look at you
click careers and you see who they're
hiring for they're hiring a senior
accountant
so you know that they're they're
counting the money counting that bread
they haven't
then they need a bunch of different
warehouse operators they need a
production associate which means that
that production associate is going to
report to someone uh so you know there's
like a huge
like a pretty meaningfully sized
meaningful sized team here
this company's only a year old who
started it
i'm not sure who started it let me pull
up this facebook post
basically it's called nugget comfort
it's like it looks like pillow cushions
that
it's like pillows but you can like build
with them it's almost like a combination
of legos meets pillows
yeah exactly and i don't actually know
exactly who the founder is this was
shared
in the facebook group looks like it
might be someone called hannah fussell a
former elementary school teacher um
yeah so actually nugget was launched so
it had a previous product that i think
was not geared towards young kids um and
i guess they had some kickstarter at the
beginning and then ultimately i think
covet hit um and they had to reposition
and somehow they came up with this like
children's product which i think is just
so interesting because i feel like there
are certain um certain industries like
pets or children that like people have
just like an endless budget to spend on
and so these pillows i think i think
they're like 200 bucks or something it's
only 300 it's not a lot of money
yeah it's like they call it a pillow
couch this is amazing this company this
is one of the wilder things this is
brilliant i totally understand it
what a cute cool thing uh
this is amazing
all right let's move on to public domain
review we'll do one more um this one is
just relates to something you guys have
talked about before about how certain ip
you know is not in the public domain and
then it moves into the public domain
after a period of time and so this is a
site that basically tracks all of that
stuff i think i originally found this
because apparently winnie the pooh is
going into the public domain in january
and so i think i found some article
about that and it was on the public
domain review so i think it's public
domain so what's going to happen what's
going to happen when that when that
happens what's what type of
opportunities are going to be there and
what businesses do you think are going
to pop up
so i think so just for like background
for people listening um
there's tons of obviously different
books or like the bible for example
that's in the public domain people can
like buy and sell you guys talked about
like cool millennial bibles winnie the
pooh is a book that
you know was written ages ago and then
in 2022 would go into the public domain
so i believe i think there's like
several different um things that um are
different um
not patents what's it called when
something is not in the publication
right yeah several different like
copyrights and so you need to look into
exactly what this covers versus what
else exists um but you could like for
example potentially like go and like
take a winnie the pooh book make it
modern and like resell that to um
to new customers i think so for example
on this website publicdomainreview.org
they've got a store where you can buy
prints like to put on the wall and it's
like
really sick art so you're saying like
now they can use like winnie the pooh in
that art or they can like resell old
winnie the pooh art or something like
that
yeah and what i'd be interested to find
out is specifically about merch i don't
know exactly if it's just the book right
like the book ip or if it actually has
to do with just like the ip overall but
the crazy thing about a lot of these big
franchises
pokemon hello kitty winnie the pooh
they've all done over 80 billion dollars
of sales in merch alone so a lot of
people think like okay if you're talking
about pokemon they made a lot of money
off the show it's like no they actually
didn't make that much off the show they
made a ton of money off the merch and
the same thing is true for like mickey
mouse or star wars that's where all the
money is made and so what i'd be
interested to know and i don't know the
answer to this is whether these things
moving into the public domain does that
mean like i can then go sell like a
winnie the pooh shirt i'm not sure
do uh first of all how long does a
copyright last is it 76 years i think
you are going to know this better than i
believe it's 76 years but it's pretty
messed up actually when you think about
it so like let's just say that like a
family
invented
a a person invented winnie the pooh they
they die they leave it to their family
so you're telling me after i think it's
76 years uh or it's it's death of the
creator plus 76 years ago yeah it's it's
from what i see now it's death of the
creator plus at least 50 years but it
can be extended to 70. is it 70 i
remember because it's like the there it
was like i remember the law there was a
law created that did that it's kind of
messed up actually when you think about
it that that is going to expire why
would that expire
like why i guess it depends
i mean you see the same thing with drugs
right where you don't want someone to be
able to like capitalize on something
forever and i think probably has to do
with like
the public benefits from something being
in a free market over time yeah because
of that [__] because if i bought a piece
of property and a piece of land and
like wouldn't that be weird if like on
the third generation you could take back
that land
i guess so i wonder like yeah i wonder
how they determine
what things have these expiring
copyrights versus what things like
that that doesn't exist
i think that's interesting i would like
to learn more about that but sorry go
ahead about publicdomainreview.org
well it's just another one of those
sites where you're like wow that's one
an interesting site where you can kind
of browse and see like what is moving
into the public domain but it's a
beautiful site it's very fun to read
yeah it also gets i mean not a crazy
amount of traffic but 500 000 page views
a month and so i wonder actually i
didn't notice they are selling art or
like different collections i was
wondering how they were monetizing but
it must be through that this is awesome
i love this website you want to do one
more
um sure do you see one that you want to
do in here i mean one of the ones that
we can talk about which is just like a
super fun little thing it's like an
internet find is this foodtimeline.org
there's not much of a business
opportunity here but i just think it's
like a fun thing to browse basically
someone has gone down the internet
rabbit hole and
found like the first
citations of when a food existed so it
starts with like water and ice and then
you know you get like wheat and
and things like basically there's like a
bunch there's like hundreds of different
data points here and then of course it
moves to like 2013 which you see like
test tube burgers um but i just think
this is like an awesome thing where like
again i don't know what the business
opportunity is here but like if you have
extra time you can create really nifty
things like this online and this site
this page alone there's only like one
page here gets over like 150 000 page
views a month i think so i don't know i
just thought it was like a cool internet
find this is
awesome broccolini was only invented in
it's kind of crazy to look and see like
wait a minute like i guess it makes
sense because it's fermented but like
kimchi was invented in the seventh
century but then like you scroll down
and you're like yeah what like what we
didn't have
i don't know like
yeah like you said broccolini until 1993
or
um that's another crazy thing on here
high fructose corn syrup
1967. i would have thought that was far
sooner buffalo wings only 1964. how
intriguing this is a really really cool
website i think that the reason why i
think this is cool so this woman it's
lynne oliver she launched it in 1999.
the reason why this is cool is because i
respect so listen lynn oliver
or oliver she was born 1958 she died in
2015. she was a library and food
historian and the sole author of the
food timeline website so there's this
here's a wikipedia page i just love that
there's someone who's this weird and
quirky enough to dedicate time to do
this because i love people like that and
people who are crazy enough to put all
their energy into something like this
exactly i just think like this is the
coolest thing ever and whoever
actually created this like thank you for
for doing that i've actually one related
business opportunity oh listen to this
according to the wikipedia the site's
domain supposedly support uh expires in
2025 but as of september 2020 uh the the
hue is database shows that it's set to
lapse on april 2022 because she died so
she died and now it's set to go out go
out on april 2022. so there you go
speaking of copyrights
there you go one i guess food related
opportunity
have you ever looked up like
healthiest fast food or like healthiest
cheese or like totally do you remember
that book you're you're not american so
i don't know if they have this in canada
but it was called eat this not that
yes
such a good book series and i would like
use it to figure out like what's not
what's a good like if i want to eat a
burger what's the healthiest burger at a
fast food place
so you're not the only one and i
discovered this because i think one day
i was looking up something ridiculous
like healthiest cheese um and so a ton
of people are searching this every
single month so i think some of these
numbers are old but something like
healthiest cereal which we all know like
cereal is not good for you um fifty
thousand uh searches per month
healthiest bread
thirty thousand searches a month
healthiest cheese twenty thousand and
then there's also a ton of search volume
for things like yeah like healthiest
meal at taco bell or something like that
which i just love because it's like it
just shows again this problem where it's
like people want to eat healthy but
they're realistically in some cases like
unable to but it also reminds me of
something that
uh peter lovells did with his like nomad
list site which is basically i call it
your listicle is my opportunity so
whenever you go you made up that phrase
yes i've been thinking about it for ages
but i like
basically whenever i search something
and the
all of the results on that page are
listicles right so you look up like
healthiest cheese and you get to a site
and just like five
it's like a long article with like five
types of cheese and you're like oh my
god like this should be easier right and
there's so many sites that have
basically found things with a lot of
search volume and made it easier like
that's what nomad list does he's like
you know what there's all these like
variables and you can play with them
yourself i'm going to collect this data
so that instead of getting a
bunch of listicles when you look up like
hot place in june to go traveling he's
like giving you that information so you
can access it yourself right he's
basically like refining the information
um and you've seen tons of other people
do this i think like that was basically
like rich barton's
strategy right when he built things like
media yeah kind of but listen
i
i will help someone do this or if they
want to partner with me i'll do this so
here's what i'm going to do
i bet you i can make a fair bit of money
like
ten thousands of dollars total but like
have a business that makes single-digit
thousands of dollars you could do this
in 30 days
here's what i would do here's what i
would do
so
steph have you so we're doing this
contest called emma uh i forget what
it's called actually but people are
taking our clips and they're turning
them into tick-tock videos and they're
posting them on tiktok and they're
getting
tons of views so the
mfm clips in a matter of like i think we
only launched it seven days ago but i
forget it's less than 10 days
uh in that short amount of time that
hashtag has
around 10 million views meaning kids
have made videos that have 10 million
views um on tick tock it's crazy there's
a couple videos i think there's one
video um that has like 1.3 million views
and there's a whole bunch of other
videos that have about or over a million
and for sure hundreds of thousands and
these guys are killing it and so the way
that they did it they created like a
handle called like mfm clips or like the
hustle's pod or hustlers die like they
just they made these things from scratch
and in literally seven days a couple of
them have a million views what i would
do is create a tick tock page that says
craving a chicken sandwich don't eat the
popeye ones eat because it has this
grams of fat they use these types of
chemicals instead eat the chick-fil-a
one because it has this or like craving
a cereal don't eat this eat this why and
then you'd be like you want more go to
this website and you create like a wire
cutter style website that does this and
you for sure
for sure can make a
really good revenue like thousands of
dollars we're talking off of
affiliate websites uh an affiliate
website and then eventually do brand
advertising deals without a doubt i
would bet that would and and that would
get popular if you had the right face
you need like a hip tick-tock or
young-looking person to do this it would
absolutely crush
totally i mean i feel like
just the tick-tock side of things like
that's going to trend no matter what and
then there's so much search volume for
this stuff that like you build up that
sustainable business over time and
there's so many queries for this so if
people are actually gonna go build this
i want someone to do that go to ahrefs
go to the keywords explorer enter
healthiest food and then if you go to
matching terms it'll basically give you
this like list of terms uh that are
similar so you can see like healthiest
food which we already talked about but
also like healthiest taco healthiest
breads healthiest breakfast healthiest
restaurant has the healthiest starbucks
healthiest mexican food and you just
like go down the line and there's like
how many there's like hundreds of terms
already just like seated there for you
and what's crazy is i was actually
pretty surprised to see that the keyword
difficulty for a lot of these was not
very high like i would have thought if
someone told me their search volume for
this stuff i would have thought like oh
someone's already tackled this no no no
no
i'm not i just googled healthiest cereal
and like pure pure wow ranks number one
i can outright yeah wow exactly it's
like thrillist or like health line and
you're like someone should go and create
like a site just for this and it'll rank
surprisingly quickly if you can target
the right keywords
this is just fantastic the um eat this
is uh so eatthis.com kind of does that
it's owned by galvanized media so
whatever i do is i go to these websites
i scroll all the way down to see who
owns the copyright galvanized media is a
website that owns like a ton of
different stuff they don't eat this not
that they own travelicious they own
celeb well and a bunch of other stuff i
would i bet you i could figure out how
much money these guys make but i would
imagine like
in the 20 or 30 million range if i had
to guess based off the website um
probably a really good business
wow and i mean you can start with
healthiest stuff and then obviously like
expand past that but that's actually
like a surprisingly
well i mean i guess not surprisingly i
think that's a big niche not so niche
niche wow okay let's wrap up with two
more things so okay you had something in
here about chess and this guy magnus who
you you're like this chess nerd you're a
chess pop you're a chess prodigy you go
to uh chess.com and you play there
you're no you're known for being a chess
person you had some amazing stats about
this guy can you tell me about this well
so if people don't follow chess magnus
is the number one chess player in the
world but the cool thing about magnus i
read this the other day is that unlike
many athletes if you want to call chess
a sport
he's actually managed to already um kind
of build a little business empire so
what a lot of you know celebrities or
athletes do is they focus on like
getting paid at the time but then they
really really struggle to build up any
sort of equity in like a product or a
brand that they're building which as
most people know the way that you you
know actually accrue wealth is through
equity we'll talk about that with tyler
perry
he's managed to create this guy magnus
how old is he
he's not very old he's only 31. it looks
like he was like a gm by the time he was
like 14 or something um wow and he's
like kind of good looking or like he's
cool looking he like it looks like he's
kind of charismatic he's just like like
there's a story here it's not like he's
just good at chess he's like he seems
like a like a like a like an interesting
person in itself
yeah he's 31 so he's uh he's not old at
all and yeah there's like videos of him
when he's like 12 and they're like
filming him at
i think like world championships and
stuff so he was really talented really
early um and now he's only 31 he's built
up a little empire so not only does he
like compete in chess still and um i
think he streams on twitch and all that
stuff sometimes but he also built his
own little company it's called magnus
chess so if you go to
see what the url is magnus chess
carlson.com okay oh sorry it's play
magnus.com they get redirected um he has
this plus membership i don't know
exactly what you get from it but it's 14
a month and here's some of the stats um
basically
his company play magnus already is a
publicly traded company has 250
employees uh 4 million registered users
and a market cap because it's public of
115 million dollars already how much
revenue does this make
so
i don't know how much it makes currently
but i mean let's look it up it's a
publicly traded company and it's
publicly traded in
france i think or is it nor i actually
don't know where it's publicly traded so
it's definitely new yeah it's in france
fra i think it's it's in euros
uh
wow this is amazing who would have
thought does he own this
he owns a stake in it so he owns
um not you know not a ton but he still
owns i think
uh
oh actually
never mind he owns 85
of the business
holy crap that's amazing
yeah so this guy's this is amazing and
so do you know what's the sales
so it looks like revenue um last quarter
was 5 million so it's doing around 20
million actually it's grown a lot
recently so it's only started looks like
in 2019 2020 had total revenue of 20 or
sorry 8 million dollars but it's you
know last quarter was five so it's
trending towards 20 million dollars wow
and that's recurring revenue so that's a
subscription yep
this is amazing and he owns 85 of this
so he basically has a has a 120 or
something like that million dollar net
worth just off of this yeah so it looks
like i'm getting a little confused
there's something called magnus chess
and then there's something called play
magnus so actually i think he owns only
nine percent of play magnus but then he
owns something else
uh
which i think is like a streaming
platform called magnus chess but either
way he owns a substantial amount of of
one of them magnus chess and he's worth
several million
wow so we and we also actually covered
chess.com chess.com uh i think it might
be mostly bootstrapped and it gets
something like have you seen what's the
monthly uniques of chess.com have you
looked it's super high yes i have like
like 150 million i think
chess.com currently has a yeah 150
million monthly uniques and i've heard
rumors that it's a multi-billion dollar
company
i mean people pay a lot for it because
they've actually built in some pretty
cool features so light chess is a
competitor like chess some people like
because it's more like indie but
chess.com has like if you go on there
you can play and then after your game
it'll basically say like
actually here all your blunders your
mistakes and this is actually like
exactly where you went wrong and it's
interesting because those are the things
people used to pay coaches for like when
i was little playing chess a coach would
come over once a week and he'd like sit
down and i'd go to tournaments and at
tournaments you'd write down your moves
and then we'd like study them after and
he'd be like see that move like do you
see how like eight moves later that
really hurt you but chess.com has that
basically like built into the software
where they're like see like that's where
you went wrong this is crazy this is
awesome ben texted me or like slacked me
while we were doing this and he goes
steph's been uh spitting fire for the
last 50 minutes so this is badass you
definitely have to come on again um and
there's like way more notes here if i
was you selfishly i want to say don't
share this and we'll do another one in
the next next week or the week after ben
what do you think what do you think
about this
i just got i was getting flack the other
day for giving you guys too many a's
uh
so uh
but this one really was like an a plus
i uh steph i
i know you've got your course and it's
doing well but you should do another
course on like how you do research
people i i do kind of want to screenshot
this doc like ben that's what people say
to us
they tell me and sean that you're saying
she's even better she's better she's
better than you she's better than you at
this
uh it depends i think so you and sean
are like
a plus entertainers i gotta work on that
and i know it's something i gotta work
on you guys are so good at like making a
conversation flow all your like funny
bits um and so i think like yeah i mean
i can share how i do some research on
give me some credit ben we do this two
or three times a week steph's doing this
yeah once everything's true it's true
you do it twice a week but it's just and
so it does like it's a little unequal
because this dock that steph has is just
like chock full of really it's amazing
yeah this is me
i'm down to come on anytime i was a
little nervous to come back on every
time i come on like you know the first
time it was sometime in 2020 you guys
had maybe like 5 000 listens an episode
and then like it's gone up so much since
then that every time i'm like dude you
guys just had like hassan minaj you've
had garyvee and i'm like i'm just this
like trans analyst or i still feel that
way so yeah if people like it i'm happy
to come on anytime but um if not we can
also just like open source this research
i don't i don't think i included
anything here that i am going to build
myself i was actually previously going
to build the like healthiest x thing and
then i just realized like that's been on
my to-do list for two years so probably
never gonna happen i'm gonna ask sarah
i'm gonna go to the other room right now
tell my wife sarah i'm like hey do this
she should i mean seriously this is like
the reason i had it on my list is
because a lot of the ideas that i've
shared in the past i'm like yeah those
are cool ideas but like can you really
do it and can you do with not that much
money and is it pretty likely to succeed
right those are like the variables and
this one like checks those boxes
dude that's awesome thank you this is
badass um we're going to wrap up if
steph what's your handle on twitter
steph smith io or jeff smith io and i'm
just going to plug my podcast again
because i'm trying to grow it just like
ben is um it's called the [__] you don't
learn in school
all right sick thank you and that was uh
you do it with calvin your uh your
boyfriend your fiance uh yeah good dude
uh all right thank you talk soon
thanks guys
about to see my first million got to the
safe and it's filling up got to the bank
it's not big enough